Welcome to now you see it when
characters drought in movies,
they're gone forever,
but more than just the character leaves.
They always take something with them.
Maybe they take away fear,
a friendship,
trust in others or a desire to go
somewhere new,
but what happens when a character starts
drowning and survives?
She's not gone forever,
but instead he's alive,
but he isn't just alive.
He's alive all over again.
He supposed to be dead when he rises up
again,
key changes,
but change isn't the right word.
It's more violent than change.
He's reborn.
Oh
Wow.
Let's look at drowning more symbolically
in the truman show.
Truman lives on an island,
caged from reality.
He's been conditioned to fear the
outside world after the drowning of his
father.
Finally,
he sails out of his world and confronts
the next nearly drowning in the process.
It's the same pattern we see in baptism,
death and rebirth.
Through the medium of water,
Truman goes and still scared of the
outside world and comes out ready.
He died and was born again.
In any drowning scene,
we see symbolic rebirth,
which originates from the Judeo
Christian sacrament of baptism.
A new believer is taking completely
underwater,
dies out of his old self in his report
and in his identity as a follower of
Christ.
The preacher done,
washed away all my sins and
transmission.
It's a straight now from here on out and
have an everlasting my.
What are you talking about?
We got bigger fish to fry using water as
death and rebirth.
Imagery has been used for centuries in
literature,
but it has since found its way into
film.
Every drowning experience has a
different meaning based on the context.
Whoever causes you to nearly drown is
the symbolic enemy and whoever saves you
is your symbolic saved.
This includes drowning yourself,
am saving yourself,
and if you're unable to say someone
else,
that represents losing a part of
yourself.
If that person was close to you,
baptism,
imagery is not restricted to violent
drowning.
We can see the same death and rebirth
more subtly in say a shower seat or a
sewage drain followed by a torrential
downpour while not as a parent.
Any scene where a character gets
cleansed with water can represent a
death and rebirth for the character.
The shower scene in psycho has baptism.
Imagery actress Janet Leigh said in her
book on the film,
Marion had decided to go back to
Phoenix,
come clean and take the consequence.
So when she stepped into the bathtub,
it was as if she were stepping into the
baptismal waters.
The spray beating down on her was
purifying the corruption from her mind,
purging the evil from her soul.
She was a virgin again,
tranquil at peace in the shower.
She's causing herself of her since in
her attempt,
though she gets murdered and fails in
her baptism.
Countless films use water as a way of
showing a deep internal change for a
character.
So someone goes under water,
whether they're hiding,
feeling trapped,
getting super powers are falling out of
an exploding plane.
Remember that getting dunked underwater
represents a part of them dying and
another part being reborn,
or maybe it's just a way to get a kiss
from Wendy peppercorn.